you've done a podcast yourself
uh a broken record podcast and just
you've done conversation too
so
what have you learned from that process
about the art of conversation and also
maybe what advice would you give
to this
uh to me about how
what to do with conversation like what
is interesting to you about conversation
one of the things that i i like
is to not
feel like
it's
there's any stakes or that it's actually
almost that it's not happening like the
fact that
when i came in you were setting up
cameras
made it less good from for me i knew
that that would impact the conversation
in a negative way the best version of it
would be
if we didn't see the cameras
and if we were and we didn't see any
technology and we were just sitting at
this table having a conversation maybe
even if we were mic'd beforehand
would be okay
if it was necessary but then we were
just sitting here having a conversation
no people in the room nothing and
feeling like we're just having a
conversation i feel like it would get
closer to um
closer to
the relaxed feeling
same thing we do in studios like you
know you've heard of red light fever you
know when artists get nervous when like
they play a song great and then the tape
starts rolling and they can't play it
and it's we're all we're all to some
degree like that we when you were with
paul mccartney i mean you're
did you were you cognizant of cameras we
had the room black
everybody who was working there was
dressed in black
everything was invisible that we were
lit in a way where
even though there were probably
20 people between 12 and 20 people
working in the room
within
three minutes of starting the
conversation
paul and i were alone in the room so it
that was the feeling on occasion you'd
hear a noise and it would be weird
people we also had nobody was allowed to
wear shoes
because it had to we were trying to
create this
intimate space and and i know from in in
the recording studio
when we're recording
if even one person is there that's just
watching and not working you know like
does like there's usually
i'm usually there and an engineer is
there technically making it happen
if anyone else is in the room it's
different because then it goes from
this moment where the person's doing a
performance to the sense
or where the person is
feeling something internally and we're
capturing it
to the the other version is they're
performing for someone it's so
interesting so like to push back in the
alternatives here so one
about the third person not to make
people self-conscious but i find that
i'm so torn on that
because sometimes when that person
like um
so evan's in the room here he's been in
the room before he's a huge fan of yours
by the way uh so
he'll
he'll nod
yeah yeah he'll get excited he's like
and you can see that nodding and for
some reason for me he's like yeah yeah
you get it like
yeah you get excited together i mean
that's that third person can be like a
really special
so having an audience
uh
when it's a friend or somebody that has
that love in them it depends on the
performer
right yeah some people really
thrive
in front of an audience
and you're saying you like that simple
intimacy of what i would like that the
reality of it not being i want it to be
as far from a performance as possible
got it and if if someone
i'll tell you a story a story that just
happened and it was viewed as kind of a
it seemed uncool in the moment to the
person that it happened to
it wasn't at all
um
we were recording new chili peppers
album which is coming out i think any
day now like
i don't know what today's date is but
within the next it maybe by the time
this airs it will be out
and um
the band was playing in the studio
and it was ripping because they play
they're incredible
and um
one of the members walked through the
control room after a particularly great
performance
and um the engineer said
wow that solo was really great
and the person who heard this said
please don't say that and walked away
it's like it it was not it it just
changed yeah
this feeling of we're in this place
where we're doing this thing and there's
there is no outside world yeah you know
we're we're doing this for us we're
going as deep as we can for us
and as soon as there's an
acknowledgement to someone else in a way
it breaks
the concentration of being inside of it
you